WE KNOW THAT JOSH ALLEN WILL
BE IN BUFFALO.
FOR MANY MANY YEARS
TO COME.
HE IS NUMBER TWO, ON THE
HORSE.
THAT IS, THAT IS A HIGH DEGREE
OF DIFFICULTY,
THROWING THE BALL. THAT'S ONE
THING TO HAVE A MOVING TARGET.
IT'S ANOTHER THING TO BE ON A
HORSE, THAT'S MOVING WHILE
YOU'RE ALSO TRYING TO GET THE
MOVING TARGET, BUT ALAN MADE
THAT STEP
THAT LEAP.
LAST YEAR.
DRAMATIC
IMPROVEMENT STUNNING
IMPROVEMENT, BECOMING THE GUY,
THE BILLS HOPED HE WOULD BE
NOBODY KNOWS WHAT A GUY'S
GOING TO BE WHEN THEY MAKE
THEM, A TOP TEN PICK LAST YEAR
ALLEN BECAME THAT GUY, WHAT
WAS THE BIGGEST DIFFERENCE YOU
SAW IN JOSH
ALLEN FROM
2019 TO
2020.
WHAT DECISION MAKING? I THINK
THAT'S THE BIGGEST THING. YOU
KNOW, ALWAYS BEEN THE TALK
ABOUT ACCURACY AND IT'S LIKE,
NO, HE'S ALWAYS BEEN ABLE TO
HIT THE BULLSEYE. IT'S JUST
SOMETIMES HE TRIES TO HIT THE
BULLSEYE,
YOU KNOW, IN BETWEEN
FOUR DEFENDERS THERE WITH
LIKE THEIR
THERE. THAT'S WHAT WE WERE
TRYING TO LIKE, WASH OUT OF
HIS FOOTBALL GAME TO A DEGREE.
SO I THINK THAT'S THE BIGGEST
DIFFERENCE IN WHAT WE SAW.
YOU KNOW, AS FAR AS JOSH
ALAN NEXT-LEVEL STUFF, ALSO
THEY WENT ALL IN ON THEM
TO WITH GETTING STUFF ON DIGS
AND ALSO OPENING UP THE
OFFENSE LIKE THE THINGS WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THAT MAYBE
ROGERS
AND RUSSELL WILSON HAVEN'T
HAD, YOU KNOW, THEY WOULD TO
THE CHIPS IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
TABLE,
MCDERMOTT DESERVES A LOT OF
CREDIT
DEFENSIVE COACH, WHO FINALLY
JUST WENT WHAT GO?
THIS GUY'S A STUD.
LIKE
LET HIM GO
LET HIM FLY.
YOU KNOW, IS THIS DECISION
MAKING IN ZEN MASTER STUFF
OF AARON RODGERS
QUALITY YET?
NO, IT'S NOT BUT IT'S NOT
FAR BEHIND
THE
DECISION MAKING SPECIAL, HE
KNOWS EVERYTHING THAT'S GOING
ON ON THE FIELD, IT'S STILL
REALLY GOOD AND THEN TO ME,
WHERE HE GOT THE ADVANTAGE
OVER ROGERS,
YOU KNOW, AS IS AGAIN.
IT'S IT'S WHAT HE MAKES
HAPPEN. WHEN THE NORMAL PLAY
IS NOT THERE
AND JOSH ALAN
YOU KNOW, YOU COULD.
YOU COULD ARGUE
TEAM SUCCESS
AS A FULL TEAM
WAS PREDICATED
MORE ON ONE PLAYER THAN JOSH
ALAN. I MEAN, IT REALLY WASN'T
HIS SKILL. SET IS
UNBELIEVABLE. YOU KNOW, HIS
FIRST OFF BEATING THE BLITZ
DOING ANYTHING LIKE THAT, LIKE
MY KEYS. HE'S NEXT LEVEL LIKE
HERE MIKE. HE KNOWS HE'S HOT
HERE BUT HE GOES A
WAIT I CAN MAKE THIS GUY MISS
AND GET A BIGGER COMPLETION
DOWN THE FIELD. SCREW THE
FOUR YARD COMPLETION. I'M
GOING TO GET A 20 YARD
COMPLETION. YOU KNOW, HERE
MANIPULATING THE COVERAGE.
LOOKING TO THE LEFT
KNOWING HE'S GOT DIGS TO THE
RIGHT, RIGHT? THIS IS
ROGERS TYPE STUFF.
HE'S REALLY, REALLY GOOD AT
IT. AND THEN
BOOM, LIKE AN EFFORTLESS,
FLAT-FOOTED
40-YARD THROW LIKE, ARE YOU
KIDDING ME? AND THEN THE
SCRAMBLING, YOU KNOW, HE IS
HIM AND MAHOMES ARE THE BEST
SCRAMBLERS IN THE NFL, THE
BEST SCRAMBLERS. AND WHEN I
SAY SCRAMBLING, I MEAN BEHIND
THE LINE OF SCRIMMAGE
BUYING TIME MAKING THINGS
HAPPEN, HERE'S ANOTHER NEWS
FLASH FOR YOU, OTHER THAN
LAMAR JACKSON AND KYLER MARIE,
JOSH,
ALLEN'S THE
THE BEST RUNNING QUARTERBACK
AND FOOTBALL TOO. HE'S ONE OF
THE THREE BEST RUNNING
QUARTERBACKS IN THE SPORT.
HE'S A REAL THREAT DOWN IN
THE RED ZONE
WHEREVER, AND THEN
LIKE THIS DIRT AND
22.
LIKE ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
LIKE
JUST SIT THERE.
LASER DOWN THE MIDDLE.
I MEAN, IT JUST DOESN'T
MATTER. SO MANY INCREDIBLE
PLAYS ALWAYS, YOU KNOW,
EVERY GAME YOU LOOK AT
IT'S PHENOMENAL. AND TO ME,
THAT'S WHERE I STARTED TO GIVE
THEM THE EDGE OVER. ROGERS TO
GO. WAIT, HE TAKES,
WHAT'S THERE WITH
IN THE NORMAL RHYTHM OF THE
OFFENSE, BUT IF NOTHING'S NOT
THERE.
I MEAN, THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS
THOUGH. NOTHING WAS THERE ARE
NO AND NO BIG DEAL. 40-YARD
LASER ON THE RUN AND THEN
HERE'S THE RUNNING ASPECT.
I MEAN IT'S A GUY THAT'S,
YOU KNOW, YOU HAVE TO DEFEND
IT WHICH ALLOWS THEM TO THROW
THAT BALL TO KNOCKS THERE. BUT
YOU HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT THAT
ASPECT OF HIS GAME.
OH HERE'S THIS. I MEAN THIS IS
MAHOMES STUFF
FADE AWAY. DROP IT IN THE
PERFECT SPOT.
TOUCHDOWN.
JOSH ALAN,
YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU REALLY
BREAK IT DOWN,
THEN
AGAIN, I'M NOT A STACK GUY.
AND YOU LOOK AT
IT'S
AMAZING. PEOPLE GOT TO STOP
BEING HEY, IT'S
2021. JOSH. ALAN'S A
SUPERSTAR STOP BEING A HATER,
EVERYBODY, HE'S HERE TO STAY.
HE'S A PHENOMENAL
PHENOMENAL TALENT.
DO YOU REMEMBER WHEN?
WHEN WE FIRST REALIZED?
YEAH,
THAT THIS GUY IS AN UNCANNY
RUNNER. DO YOU REMEMBER WHEN
THAT WAS
WELL-LIKED TWO YEARS AGO THAT?
RIGHT? OR WHEN HE FIRST
THERE'S THREE YEARS AGO WAS
THAT EVERYBODY, YOU KNOW, HE
HAD SEPTEMBER
23,
2018. THE BILLS WERE
SEVENTEEN POINT UNDERDOGS AT
MINNESOTA. OH, YOU'RE RIGHT. I
LEAFED EITHER, YOU ACTED AT
LAMBEAU FIELD. YEAH, JUMPING
OVER ANTHONY BAR DIVING
INTO THE END ZONE.
WE WERE
HOLY CRAP.
WHAT IS THIS?
WHAT IS, WHAT IS
THIS HELL? THAT'S ABOUT TO BE
UNLEASHED ON THE NFL.
NO ONE KNEW,
NO ONE KNEW THAT HE COULD DO
IT. THERE'S SO MUCH CRITICISM
OF HIS ACCURACY AND YEAH HE'S
GOT A DEEP BALL BUT, YOU
KNOW
IT'S SOMETIMES IT CONNECTS,
SOMETIMES IT DOESN'T ALL THE
STUFF OF THE WYOMING AND
NEEDED.
THE GUY IS PHENOMENAL,
RUNNING THE FOOTBALL
AND THE BILLS
IN 2019 WAS WHEN WE KIND OF
SPOTTED, MAYBE THEY'RE BEING
CAREFUL ABOUT IT. THEY DON'T
WANT TO
EXPOSE HIM TO IT.
INJURY,
THEY'RE VERY SELECTIVE AND
WHEN THEY DESIGN IT.
BUT
WHEN HE NEEDS TO DO IT, WHEN
HE HAS TO DO IT WHEN HE
CHOOSES TO DO IT, REALLY IS
SPECIAL AND IT ADDS AN ELEMENT
TO THE GAME. IT'S IT'S
IT'S A TWIST ON WHAT WE TALKED
ABOUT WITH KYLER MARIE. YOU
GOT TO BE CONCERNED ABOUT, HE
GOT TO BE AWARE OF IT
AND THE AWARENESS OF IT, THE
ALLOWANCE YOU HAVE FOR IT
PUTS MORE STRESS ON YOUR
ABILITY TO COVER THE
RECEIVERS. BECAUSE IF YOU
COMPLETELY BLANK AT THE
RECEIVERS, THEN HE'S GOT AN
OPENING FOR 40 YARDS TO THE
ENDZONE. DEFINITELY, HE CAN
RUN THAT WAY
AND LIKE
THIS IS WHERE I LOVE THEM OR
ROGERS OF, YOU KNOW, YEARS
PAST
WHEN HE DOES BREAK THE POCKET,
HE DOESN'T LOOK TO RUN FIRST
HE WANTS TO BREAK THE POCKET
AND MANIPULATE COVERAGE AND
THROW A 40 OR 50 YARD LASER
BUT THEN WHEN HE GOES WAIT,
YOU GUYS AREN'T GOING TO BEND.
YOU'RE GOING TO STAY WAY BACK
THERE. OKAY, I'LL RUN AND
THAT TO ME IS THE WAY YOU PLAY
FOOTBALL RIGHT NOW AT THE
QUARTERBACK POSITION IN 2021.
THAT'S WHY THEY'RE THERE
THEY'RE ALMOST, YOU KNOW,
INDEFENSIBLE
UNLESS THEY'RE PLAYING A TEAM
THAT JUST, YOU KNOW, GOT
THEIR NUMBER OR
THEY'RE COMPLETELY OUT.
OUTMATCHED THAT DAY AND YOU'RE
RUNNING, YOU'RE RIGHT, IT WAS
2018 AND TO ADD TO THAT,
YOU KNOW, HE HAD TWO GAMES
IN A ROW,
WHERE HE RUSHED FOR A HUNDRED
YARDS AND THEN THE THIRD GAME
HE RUSHED FOR 99 YARDS.
HE WOULD HAVE BEEN THE FIRST
QUARTERBACK EVER THAT TIME TO
RUN FOR A HUNDRED YARDS THREE
WEEKS IN A ROW. THE FIRST ONE
EVER,
YOU KNOW, HIS RUNNING IS A
REAL THREAT,
IT IS SCRAMBLING, IS A REAL
THREAT,
YOU KNOW,
EVEN FOR THE
GUNSLINGER THAT HE IS,
HERE'S ANOTHER STAT FOR YOU.
THIS IS OUR,
NOBODY'S HAD MORE RUSHING
TOUCHDOWNS TO THIS
2018.
SINCE JONATHAN JOSH
ALLEN IN THE RED ZONE
GUNSLINGER. RIGHT? HE'S
RECKLESS.
FORTY TWO, TOUCHDOWN PASSES
ZERO INTERCEPTIONS
AND HIS CAREER IN THE RED
ZONE,
42 TO 0. THAT'S LIKE INSANE
STUFF RIGHT THERE. SO
THAT'S WHERE LIKE WE GOT TO
GET OVER SOME OF THESE
NARRATIVES AND EVERYTHING LIKE
THAT.
I MEAN, HE WENT THROUGH LIKE,
YOU KNOW,
UNBELIEVABLE
AMOUNT OF TIME THIS YEAR
OF ATTEMPTS WITHOUT
INTERCEPTIONS. I MEAN, SO ALL
THESE NARRATIVES WERE
BUSTED LAST
LAST YEAR,
HE IS A SUPERSTAR.
HE COULD HAVE BEEN THE MVP OF
FOOTBALL LAST YEAR. YOU COULD
HAVE MADE THAT CASE,
YOU KNOW. AGAIN, 40 TOUCHDOWN,
PASS THERE'S A 37
TOUCHDOWN PASSES,
HE RAN FOR ANOTHER NINE OR
EIGHT
EVERYTHING LIKE THAT.
THEIR DEFENSE WAS JUST A
MIDDLE-OF-THE-ROAD DEFENSE.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE A RUNNING
GAME.
I MEAN JOSH
ALLEN FOR MY MONEY. YES. IS
WITHOUT A DOUBT. ONE OF THE
TWO BEST QUARTERBACKS IN THE
GAME RIGHT NOW.
NOW.
I'M SITTING HERE TRYING TO
THINK OF WHAT IT'S GOING TO
TAKE TO GET MORE PEOPLE TO BUY
INTO THAT. I
DO. I SEE TWO THINGS. VERY
SIMPLE, VERY SIMPLE
ONE,
WHEN YOU GET YOUR OPPORTUNITY
ON A BIG REGULAR SEASON STAGE,
YOU GOTTA SHOW UP, YES,
BECAUSE LAST YEAR, MY THAT
GAME AGAINST THE CHIEFS. YES.
DIDN'T SHOW UP, RIGHT?
YOU
GOTTA YOU GOTTA SEIZE THE
MOMENT AT NIGHT
WHEN EVERYONE'S WATCHING
AND IN THE POSTSEASON
YOU GOT TO BRING IT AND YOU
GOT TO, YOU GOT TO TAKE DOWN
THE BIG DOGS, YOU KNOW, THE
GAME AGAINST THE RAVENS WAS
NOT.
I KNOW, BUT IT WASN'T. I KNOW
IT WASN'T,
IT WASN'T WORKING THAT NIGHT,
BUT I'M
YEAH, RIGHT, RIGHT, BUT I'M
SAYING
IT. THE PLANETS HAVE TO LINE
UP FOR JOSH ALAN.
SO EVERYONE CAN SEE,
YOU'RE RIGHT,
WHAT YOU SEE ON FILM
AND WHAT POCKETS OF THE
COUNTRY, SEE
AT 1 P.M. EASTERN
ON A SUNDAY. YEAH. JUST LIKE
THIS, YOUR FIRST GAME OF THE
SEASON AGAINST THE STEELERS,
IT'S GOING TO BE ONE O'CLOCK
EASTERN ON A SUNDAY WHEN
EVERYTHING ELSE IS GOING ON.
HE MAY HAVE AN INCREDIBLE GAME
SHRED THAT DEFENSE IT'S NOT
GOING TO BE AS APPRECIATED AS
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
IF IT HAPPENS ON
SUNDAY NIGHT, MONDAY NIGHT,
TAKE DOWN THE STEELERS LATE IN
THE YEAR, ON SUNDAY NIGHT, BUT
I'M TALKING ABOUT WHEN YOU
COME UP AGAINST. YEAH,
CHIEFS
RAVENS. BIG SPOT.
THAT'S THOSE ARE THE MOMENTS
WHEN PEOPLE ARE BUZZING THE
NEXT DAY. YEAH. AND THEY'RE
LIKE, WOW, WE REALLY HAVE
TO TAKE
THIS GUY SERIOUSLY.
ONE OF THE BEST QUARTERBACKS
IN FOOT. NO NO I HEAR YOU.
I DO. I THINK HE NEEDS A FEW
MORE OF THOSE MOMENTS THE KIND
OF LIKE YOU KNOW HAMMER IT
HOME AND STAPLE IT DOWN
FOR THE REST OF YOU KNOW. YEAH
THE THE
NOT THE CASUAL FOOTBALL
VIEWER OR ANYTHING LIKE THAT,
YOU'RE RIGHT. BUT YET STILL
IN THAT THOUGH HE DOESN'T GET
A CREDIT LIKE HE SHOULD FOR
BEATING PITTSBURGH ON A
SUNDAY NIGHT FOOTBALL GAME OR
YOU KNOW THE MAGIC HE PULLED
OFF AGAINST SAN FRANCISCO IN A
MONDAY NIGHT FOOTBALL GAME,
WHERE HE MADE PLAYS, THAT
MADE KYLE, SHANAHAN GO. I WANT
TO
DRAFT REAL ANTS BECAUSE
I'M SICK OF THESE POCKET.
QUARTERBACKS, I CAN'T STOP
THIS GUY,
RIGHT? I MEAN, ALSO
HE'S NOT GIVEN THE CREDIT LIKE
IN THE WILD-CARD GAME AGAINST
THE COLTS WHERE I'D GO,
SOMEBODY GO BACK AND WATCH THE
TV VERSION OF THAT GAME.
THE BILLS WERE
OUTPLAYED. THEY HAD NO
BUSINESS TO WINNING THE GAME.
THEY ONLY WON THE GAME BECAUSE
OF THE QUARTERBACK, THEY GOT
DOMINATED IN THE FIRST HALF
AND IT WAS
CLOSED AT
HALFTIME, ONLY BECAUSE OF
17 AND YOU'RE RIGHT. WE NEED
TO SEE. THEY NEED TO SEE MORE
OF THAT,
BUT ALSO
PEOPLE GOT TO GIVE HIM CREDIT
FOR
WHAT'S BEING DONE.
HERE
TOO AND IT'S
70 PERCENT COMPLETION
PERCENTAGE, YOU KNOW, HIGH
FOR THOUSANDS AND YARDS
PASSING THE GAME IS PUT ON
HIS SHOULDERS AND MIKE. THERE
WAS A TURNING POINT WHERE I
WENT. WHOA, THEY TRUST THEM.
IT WAS WEEK TO LAST YEAR
THEY'RE PLAYING THE MIAMI
DOLPHINS
AND I STILL THOUGHT LIKE YOU
WERE TALKING ABOUT A MINUTE
AGO,
2019. WE'RE GOING TO MANAGE
THEM A LITTLE BIT. HERE'S THE
GAME. THEY'RE DOWN 2017.
HE STARTED OUT HOT AND YOU'RE
GOING TO ALL RIGHT. NOW
THEY'RE GOING TO GO BACK IN TO
RUN THE BALL. PLAY DEFENSE,
SEAN, MCDERMOTT. THEY COME OUT
FIRST
AND 10 DOWN.
THREE, WHOO. HEY, LET'S THROW
A GO ROUTE. HERE'S THE NEXT
THROW. BEASLEY OVER THE
MIDDLE. BOOM, ON THE MUDDY.
SECOND AND 24, 24
YARD GAIN, OKAY,
THIRD AND GOAL.
HEY, YOU KNOW, THE GUY. IT'S
MAGIC TIME.
I MEAN, THIS IS IT'S HE'S AS
GOOD AS ANYBODY IN THE SPORT.
NOT NAMED PATRICK MAHOMES ARE
DOING THAT TYPE OF STUFF. SO I
WENT. OH OKAY.
BUT NOW IT'S
20 FOR 20 AND I'M GOING WELL,
SURELY THEY'LL RUN THE CLOCK
OUT HERE AND THIS IS WHEN I
WENT, WHOA,
THEY TRUST. JOSH ALAN, LIKE,
THEY'RE GOING ALL IN FIRST OFF
THAT THROW WAS INSANITY
IN THE MEMBRANE.
BUT THEN THIRD AND NINE UP
FOR DEFENSE
A HEAD COACH,
WHAT THROW T
0-YARD POST
ROUTE? LIKE THAT? THAT'S WHEN
I WENT. ALL RIGHT,
SOMETHING HAPPENED THIS
OFFSEASON WHERE THEY
JUST THEY REALIZE JOSH ALLEN
GETS IT. HE KNOWS HOW TO PLAY
THE GAME. HE'S MAKING ALL THE
RIGHT READS AND ALL
THAT TYPE OF STUFF. AND FROM
THAT POINT ON, I THINK WE WERE
ALL AMAZED WHAT WE SAW.
SAW.
THIS YEAR FOR JOSH, ALAN
HERE ARE THE KEY GAMES TO
WATCH. YEAH,
POSTSEASON BECAUSE SURELY THE
BILLS WILL GET ONE OF THE
SEVEN SPOTS IN THE AFC WEEK.
FIVE, SUNDAY NIGHT FOOTBALL AT
THE KANSAS CITY CHIEFS, THAT
IS AN EARLY OPPORTUNITY
TO PUT EVERYONE ON NOTICE THAT
THE BILLS ARE READY TO GO NEXT
LEVEL
WEEK
SIX MONDAY NIGHT FOOTBALL AT
THE TENNESSEE TITANS. ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY AND THEN
WEEKS 12 13 14
AT THE SAINTS ON A THURSDAY
NIGHT
AT THE PATRIOTS ON A MONDAY
NIGHT AND THEN
THAT LATE
BIG SPOT
FOR TWENTY FIVE PM EASTERN
GAME
AT THE TAMPA BAY BUCCANEERS.
YEAH, IT'S TOM BRADY, THOSE
GAMES.
YOU SHOW UP IN THOSE FIVE
GAMES YOU SHOPPING FOR OF
THOSE FIVE GAMES, AND YOU PUT
ON THE KIND OF SHOW THAT WE'VE
SEEN ELSEWHERE AND IT'S GET
I THINK THAT
THEY'RE JUST WILL BE A
GREATER APPRECIATION OF JOSH
ALLEN AND THE BILLS WIN AND
WIN AND WIN.
THAT'S ONE WAY TO GET IN THE
MVP CONVERSATION BUT I THINK
HE SHOULD BE BACK IN AT THIS
YEAR. THE BILL SHOULD BE AS
GOOD AS THEY WERE LAST YEAR IF
NOT BETTER
ASSUMING THAT THE VACCINE
ISSUE DOESN'T CREATE A SCHISM
IN THE LOCKER ROOM AS IT
ALREADY KIND OF HAS. YEAH, BUT
THEY STAY ON THE SAME PAGE,
THEY
FIND A WAY TO NUDGE.
TO THE NEXT LEVEL AND JOSH
ALLEN FINDS A WAY TO DO WHAT
HE JUST DID. HE DOES WHAT HE
DID LAST YEAR. YEAH, IT
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE BETTER THAN
LAST YEAR. JUST DO WHAT YOU
DID LAST YEAR
AND SHOW UP IN THOSE BIG GAMES
AND HAVE BIG MOMENTS AND TAKE
DOWN PATRICK
MAHOMES. THAT'S WHEN PEOPLE I
THINK ARE GOING TO APPRECIATE,
THEY'RE GOING TO, THEY'RE
GOING TO WARM TO THE IDEA
THAT THIS GUY IS
A TOP TWO QUARTERBACK IN THE
NFL. YEAH
I MEAN I THINK I THINK I HOPE
DO I REALLY DO YOU KNOW NOW
AGAIN BUFFALO NEEDS TO BE
BETTER TO THAT. WAS THEY PUT A
LOT ON JOSH ALAN
ALLEN LAST YEAR.
FENCES MIDDLE OF THE ROAD, NO
RUN GAME, YOU KNOW, SO
HOPEFULLY THEY CAN BE BETTER
AS A FOOTBALL TEAM
TOO BECAUSE IT'S HARD TO
SURVIVE.
WE'LL JUST GO
AND WAIT, WE'RE JUST GONNA
SHOTGUN GO ALL IN ON ONE GUY
ALL THE TIME. IT'S NOT EASY,
IT'S NOT AND AS GOOD AS THEY
ARE, AND THEY HAVE GOOD
WEAPONS ON OFFENSE. THEY
DON'T HAVE TYREE KILL AND
KELSEY AND THAT GROUP YET
THEY'RE NOT THERE TO THAT
LEVEL. BUT LAST
THING I'LL SAY HERE AND JUST
TO GO LIKE
A LITTLE BIG PICTURE HERE TO
WHAT YOU'RE SAYING AND
PIGGYBACK OFF THAT
THAT REMEMBER,
THE CHIEFS AND BILLS WHEN THEY
WERE GETTING READY TO PLAY
EACH OTHER IN THE AFC
CHAMPIONSHIP
GAME. THIS SHOULD I THINK I'LL
SHOW YOU JUST A LITTLE BIT OF
THE RESPECT?
THE PLAYERS HAVE ALREADY
AND I THINK COACHES AROUND THE
NFL FOR JOSH
ALAN CHRIS JONES, MADE A
COMMENT. IF YOU REMEMBER
LEADING UP TO THE GAME HE WENT
THEY REMIND ME OF US
A FEW YEARS AGO WITH THIS
QUARTERBACK WHO MAKES THESE
UNBELIEVABLE PLAYS. HE WAS
SAYING HE REMIND THEY REMIND
ME OF PATRICK MAHOMES AND OUR
TEAM
TO THREE YEARS AGO WITH THEIR
KIND OF JUST JUMPING ON THE
SCENE WITH THIS AMAZING
QUARTERBACK PLAY. SO THAT KIND
OF TELLS YOU,
YOU KNOW,
WHAT THE GUYS ARE DEFENDING
HIM, THINK OF THEM WHERE THEY
JUST GO. HOLY CRAP. WHEN YOU
TURN ON THE FILM, IT'S JUST
ONE PHENOMENAL PLAY AFTER
ANOTHER. AND I THINK HE'S GOT
THE RESPECT OF HIS PEERS AE NDC